so let me do a quick rundown here there
are a lot of heavy hitters here they
throw big haymakers and you do best to
avoid them or you will be you will be
facedown on the canvas so we got 13 21
22 17:48 21 18 19 24 23 and we're
starting here we go game on I couldn't
get through well alright let's run with
this I gotta get the quick wins okay how
are they gonna recapture my Knights are
gonna get pushed around let's chop that
and get castled quickly ooh not too
quickly not too quickly can I get this
dark square oh this has to be good for
me right I'm gonna win that pun it's
going down the pond is going down here
but and this rook and pawn endgame oh
we're not having a recap on endgame
let's do this and then okay so it's a
four on three majority I have a flight
square for my King so this should maybe
assure me of what she may be assure me
of okay let's do this I have my queen in
a good spot 23 seconds this guy is
moving very quick and I should pump this
up like I'm on that pond as well
okay target on f2 my queen has
controlled that diagonal so let's get on
this and keep going with actually I'm
off that diagonal now I shouldn't have
done that let's come here 13 seconds
okay let's come here trade cleans oh oh
oh check and play here and then here oh
I could have taken their rope oh I got
their book now eight seconds come on
come on come on come on come on
they are flying no stalemate please no
steal me well they resigned back to
tournament oh I thought my time might
have been ticking sometimes that happens
my time is ticking even though it seems
like their time is ticking okay there
should be five let's stop that okay I
might have something quick kick this
night around and then yeah let's kick
that night around oh yes
click resigner come on quick resign oh
wait wait wait wait no they're not gonna
resign so fast ok and now can I get this
in how Bishop takes hopefully this is
good
comes with check keep that night away
and then why did I kick that night away
LightSquared bishop s' start and discard
that pond and get castle what am i doing
not castled everything is closed over
here but not so fast now that pond is
hit and I probably just want to run with
my pond here let's come here I'm in a
pin my knight what in the world is my
knight doing what's my king doing what
am i doing there Queen trade please no
let's not take that what is my King
doing wha I still have questions to
answer here what is my knight doing ah I
don't have any it's not doing anything
uh-oh that pawns gonna push
and I can't take it 11 seconds why can't
I win this quicker my night is garbage
my night is garbage no I lost there's no
way I can win this there's no way I
could win this I'm just dropping pieces
2.9 seconds oh this is already a tough
one
oh come on give me this oh I'm down a
time
oh I got zero points no 25 command H pun
that's my a pun let's try the H pun come
on H pond save the day you know you want
to save the day that I can move in
cosmic problems can we trade how is that
short quick attack yeah if I go at the H
pond oh man this is brutal this is a
terrible start there's no recovering you
have to win like every game you got to
win every game that was terrible
terrible tricks tricks tricks everywhere
Oh is there tricks everywhere or what
let me tell you there are tricks
everywhere everywhere I have no time no
time let's take that can I please just
get a rope for free there yes I need the
free roots everybody needs a free Rooke
every now and then let me tell you
everybody needs a free book but that was
like such a crushing position I had a
night that was dead to the game because
it was hanging out and if I don't hurry
the same things gonna happen
get out of there Bishop no there goes my
rook Oh
taking it move Bishop no I'll take the
knight come on
just make things simple it would be nice
if you just made things simple there we
go now it's simpler an even simpler now
okay I can move quicker I can move
quicker oh come on take that take that
back to tournament they resigned for I
got a measly four points twelve eleven
600 I haven't even encountered the heavy
hitters the heavy hitters are ready to
give me a beating they are gonna be like
wow
you can't win being up a piece you don't
stand a chance against me back up okay
how do they Castle let's do this castle
b5 launch the b-pawn attack I want to
get on that diagonal maybe one day one
day okay d5 the liberating move in the
Sicilian let's take like this and Brooke
here next that night is scary oh no it's
not it's hyung let's come over here is
that Bishop gonna kill me not yet my
Knights around am I gonna end up in a
pin rook to see a DIF happens and I
takes Bishop to get rid of that before
it's too late
hit the knight offer Queen exchange over
here trade Queens let's go fast turn my
H pawn down and O get my knight okay can
I get my knight here
oh boy oh oh oh Knight takes oh man oh
man Luke takes there everything's
falling everything's falling
everything's falling ah defend I got to
do this I got to do that
what do I got here move rook move rook
yes I got tonight
come on golf quick let's go here let's
go that was really scary let's back up
scary positions Forks everywhere
discovered attacks you name it take the
Queen take everything oh I could have
just taken the whole house there let's
just grab that for fun and defend defend
defend some more just play here even if
it's wrong even if it's wrong just go
there
back to tournament twenty twenty sixteen
and a bunch of tens okay Winkle Winkle
Winkle Winkle here what do we got in
store for the Winkler mr. Henry Winkle
Winkle alright whatever the night takes
capture not so fast not so fast here not
so fast
okay let's castle like a good player
would do right you have to get castle
get castle do basic moves take free
pawns
why is everybody playing so fast oh I'm
losing my dark-squared bishop no he's
down he's down and out I'm looking for
Forks okay let's get that out of here
Knight c4 is strong oh why didn't they
do that okay this has got to be good
get my queen right here and then push
that night away and I here is no good
okay
push that night away am I missing
anything I hope not I might give a check
a check of risky if pawn push now I just
take it right away
resign chop chop get my Knights doing
something let's go take that pond check
come on fork for caboose key yes I'm
gonna take that rook resign let's play
here and then there check
I don't know what I'm doing go go go go
go go they're gonna start giving checks
now there we go
okay like I said and now they're gonna
and oh there's me I just had me just
follow through rip take spawn right
there was me looking for making one
where is it making two right here one
two that's a smooth one I'll take it
they forfeit on time back to tournament
eighteen thirty twenty seven twenty six
twenty I'm in seventh I'm in seventh
come on Sicilian come through come
through for me here
let's go Sicilian okay well I'm not
quite sure what that move even does okay
and now I want to get my LightSquared
Bishop I opened about he needs to see
the world he needs to see the position I
could grab that pawn let's do this and
oh man can you believe it believe it I
just dropped that pawn with check I did
not care much at all I want to recap
like this even though it's ugly my
structure I want to watch over I want to
watch over these squares right here cuz
I'm ready to take a beating if I don't I
can also look to undermine this night
maybe get my majority rolling whoa
that's a very committal move Oh killer
move oh I'm in check you can't take
pieces like that
okay now you could oh I should have
taken that G pun take the Jeep on and
then this guy next and then what guy
next this guy can always play here next
let's throw a check in just for fun just
for fun let's do it and then trade let's
get out of here
trade throw a check in let's defend that
recapture check man it's not easy it
just can't be easy can it it can't be
easy oh there's a cleaner win than this
is even cleaner win than that oh maybe
they'll miss their I'm on the rope or
not let's check
oh this I could win this right oh man
okay let's go with this get this rook
get this pawn going okay this that stay
here please don't let it be stalemate no
stalemate please don't Stanley it please
okay no Stanley go go go go go go go
five point eight okay twenty eight fifty
two thirty nine thirty twenty eight
twenty eight twenty oh here comes a big
one okay can we get this guy he moves
incredibly fast he plays very quick come
on let's go let's roll take my bishop
actually ahead on time probably because
I had a time advantage and now let's do
this and my dropping stuff okay I got a
file can I work with that let's back up
no let's do this I'm on that pawn this
could be scary for them maybe I have a
majority why would they do that that
can't be good can it let's open this up
get that night out of there somehow get
this night out of there he needs to go
is he trapped it's close to being
trapped
I can't think you just can't think
sometimes it just happens like that
where you just can't think look here I
want to be on that flight square still
come on you know you want to trade
check guard this and get my pond going
oh they were being sneaky they're being
really sneaky right there
do I win this race am I gonna win this
race please let me win the race let me
win the race why'd they do that why they
do that why they do that oh that was a
blunder on their part oh there was a
blunder on my part hey run pun
karate-chop check come back here for a
time you know you want to burn time Oh
are they gonna move quick they're gonna
miss it
yes am I gonna miss that oh go go go Oh
run king who won i won that one oh this
is so brutal you have no idea what kind
of an adrenaline rush this is oh man oh
man you're missing out you're missing
out if you're not the chess player this
is so intense
oh my bishop is bad I'm and I can't give
it up it took this is my good guy right
here my bad one is this one right here
he needs to go I should take him like
three times
no I want to hang on to him oh I'm
crushed here okay let's do this I want
my night to get to see four quick okay
run pawn run
let's do this and get still get to see
four let's still get to see four Oh
incoming get ready to run King let's
watch over that hang on a second
get ready to run run King pack up and
run you know you want to run just do it
are they gonna move huh what's wrong
they might have disconnected their
connection that thing is low here let's
go 22 21 I already have a move in right
no okay I got everything covered I could
give a check on that Square and then I'm
gonna run really really fast really
really fast
oh there what wait a second my time was
tickin what's up with that
it showed that third time was tick in
what way ah man Oh point three seconds
they were just gonna ah man it wasn't
showing that my clock was ticking did
you just see that that is not the first
time that that has happened either oh
man there's no recover from that ah that
is ridiculous oh man I could live with
the ones that I lose on because of poor
play on my part but not because I'm
waiting for my opponent to move and it's
really my clock ticking that stinks that
gets the big ass right there the big s
man
there's no coming back now absolutely no
coming back
Wow Wow
it's not happening it's not happening is
that night dead or close to it I don't
even know what I'm doing here okay let's
take that rook and let's come back
around let's take this guy I'm probably
getting okay let's see is my super fair
and right now my opponent isn't moving
I'm just basically okay I got a run to
f2 I gotta run to F to run King I'm
gonna give a rook up maybe maybe not if
you see right now is my clock moving oh
I'm on the Queen and the rook that was a
decent saying I think Bishop c5 would
have been better
let's come here I'm still on both the
Queen and rook and what now
Oh is somebody being sneaky
I think I'd get made and if I took the
Queen I almost took the bait I almost
took the bait yupper I almost fell for
the little tricks my opponent threw at
me let's do this rook takes Bishop I
take with this and I'm connected been
bad I would have got loud 52 52 52 vng a
this guy's I think is gonna give me a
draw offer I think that's his MO he's
done that in the five-minute ones I
guess it's not happening in these we've
played a couple times I think we've
split games and I got away with one last
time queenside castle c3 is on c3
they're defending let's go Knight
contribute be a contributor
let's have that's enough let's take this
and offer a queen exchange before it's
too late before it's too late
chop-chop let's stop okay get my rooks
connected okay let's get over here my
knight is stopping okay let's do that
and come over here come over here this
is a past pun okay and now let's do this
and do this before it's too late
push push push push submit this pawn on
a dark square it's got to be good
opposite color Bishop bendings um come
on why can't this be simpler okay come
over here hopefully this is a one King
and pawn endgame check okay let's grab
this and now II can't King run fast run
really fast go after those pawns you
know you want them okay they tried to be
slick and now I'm going to get this w I
can't grab the bishop no no no no no
let's go now now everything is nice and
cozy nice and cozy run pun run run run
hang on let me get that guy that's so
fast okay let's do this this is quicker
actually go with the quick ones back to
tournament 68 what I might get a half a
granola bar somehow can I get a second
this guy give me a beating put me in my
place
Oh would be nice if I reacted properly
right there let's stop the bishop from
developing okay okay and now they're
fishing for a plan here I don't know
there may be a bit thrown off ah
or are they I'm gonna I'm gonna take
like that I'm gonna I'm gonna force the
situation I want to take like this and
play on the F file right here could be
good though let's stop that night here
could be good as well Oh
uh-oh uh-oh uh-oh I'm in trouble I'm in
trouble if you didn't realize I am in
that place called trouble they missed it
I got this and I'm defending my clean ah
okay get out of there Knight is he
trapped he's not trapped
oh oh oh let's come here oh why did I do
that
um come on look at these Knights
look at these Knights talk about ugly
knights here Queen here looking for
tricks tricks of the trade here are the
tricks that's not working out that is
not working out what am I doing with
that move move this and now bishop move
and I'm on the Queen get my what are my
Knights doing could somebody please tell
me what my Knights are doing nothing
they're garbage okay I got to open this
square for my pieces there we go now
it's coming together now my pieces are
finding good squares and now I'm
connected actually finally oh I have
enough on this okay do I get there okay
I have the Queen here come on come on
come on iconic fun I got this I got this
right on the rook I'm on the night
oh they got my queen no they don't let's
do this Knight check would have been
good too look check where's the mate
it's probably mate right soon oh look
here and then mate back to tournament
quickly they're out of time yes 86 less
than 6 105 88 88 86 86 is there possibly
a chance here way leg is strong players
having a good tournament 105 Wow okay
what's going on here oh there's two
people up there there's two people up
there quick wins a quick win
quickly and click win okay once again my
light-square bishop is ridiculous it's
ridiculous that LightSquared bishop okay
now at least has a home and okay
my king is uncannily
okay now this square is where i want to
be and actually let's go over here and
stop any activity Queen takes H what am
i doing take the free pawns if they're
there Queen trade coming up I'm assuming
because my queen is in a great spot or
they're gonna be killed soon if they
don't my knight has everything strung
together I'm also missing a bunch of
forks
hang on oh my queen is close to being
trapped close is not enough though close
I know just need one square right okay
crunch double up double trouble triple
trouble let that be mate
let it be may its mate back to
tournament 106 125 118 108 106 106 come
on less than 4 I'm gonna get paired up
with somebody Big B nga again let's do
this let's do this and now what
let's stop B 5 okay now I think I'm in a
good spot I think I'm actually in a good
spot because how do they recover that F
pawn and okay now I'm gonna hang on to
that too I'm gonna hang on to all this
material my opponents giving me a lot of
material I'm gonna hang on to it all I'm
greedy be greedy actually it's not
always good to be greedy okay let's get
this and push my opponents Knights
around let's do this first it's in a pin
B for coming up I got that I got that
chop the knight and then push the ponder
in check got the Queen oh oh oh oh
resignation no resignation clean here
looking for me my clock is not ticking
okay back to tournament that was a quick
win who's in first what just happened
there once
six 125 judge fudge is here 1771 judge
fudge okay how is this happening with
these losses I don't understand here we
go here we go here we go okay they're
retreating on purpose night here killer
hang on I don't want you to get there so
quick okay um what about b6 and Bishop
to a6 Bishop to a6 incoming I got to get
rid of that night he needs to go he
needs to go he needs to go and I need to
watch out for this square oh it's very
scary right now I gotta chop this guy
and I have to deal with this Knight
I have to deal with the knight this deep
in my position or do I
or do I mm okay well here's the plan get
rid of this Knight
actually let's get rid of the Queen
first how am i doing what's time how is
the time situation
okay let's chop this and then get that
Bishop out of there and then get rid of
okay hang on hang on hang on hang on
hang on here I need to get this guy
okay there's Forks and everything though
I take my rock I'm okay with that closed
position the Knights could actually be
quite good and that's what we're gonna
be seeing I think night landing incoming
a nice post miraculously miraculously
let's go King you know you want to play
too
you know you want to play - first let's
get the king up we've got a nice rook up
and over type of stuff going in check
this is a giant pond this is a giant
pond uh let's do this no no no no no no
no what am i doing let's backtrack
okay back to tournament 146 oh yes I'm
up there one minute less than one minute
145 how much time is left less than a
minute oh those guys are gonna win
though soon right quick kill
maybe if I miss that
ah come on kick that [ __ ] up come on
fishing pole like position come on I'm
almost there I think I can I think I can
check check
come on mate we got me just move just
move just he's not moving he's an odd
mover
he's an odd mover come on you know this
is mate come on this is killing me right
here this is me I'm pretty moving it how
much time is left
fifteen fourteen thirteen come on I
can't even talk with them I'll say you
know you want to move if the chat was
available I'd be saying you know you
want to move right now come on you know
you want to move what'd I get
man second second place man how would I
miss out on oh if that guy would have
just moved
he should have moved oh so close but so
far away good games all and that's not
only spell ah okay 25:25 crown Rooskies
on that one